be um hey hey what's going on what's
going on
[Music]
it's bill burn it's time for the Monday
morning podcast for month 29 2008 - oh
happy baseball championship happy
baseball championship why am I in such a
good mood why do I want to walk down the
street with a [ __ ] bass drum kicking
my [ __ ] feet up in the air because
you're 2018 Boston Red Sox once again
our World Series champions do you
believe it I think I speak for all in
New England when I say [ __ ]
unbelievable
unbelievable I remember after 2003
thinking all I want to do is just see
these [ __ ] [ __ ] just one [ __ ]
time have a clutch [ __ ] moment and
your [ __ ] life you Red Sox wearing
[ __ ] that's where I was at all right in
the very next year they win it and I was
like you know what that's it you know
I'm in such a good mood I don't give a
[ __ ] that my phone is making noise in
the background that's what a great mood
iment all I wanted to see was just some
winner once not only to get to see him
when it once twice three times four
times there one buying the Patriots so
all you haters out there just in case
you lost count in this century we've won
five Super Bowls four World Series
titles an NBA championship and a Stanley
Cup and one of those soccer
championships MLS whatever their but
when it championships and stuff I don't
even give a [ __ ] about all right and for
all you guys don't you didn't get old
after a while don't you get tired of it
no it's [ __ ] awesome it's [ __ ]
awesome you know and you know if it
doesn't happen to us I hope it happens
to you someday unless you're in [ __ ]
New York or in Montreal or a Laker fan
other than that I got no [ __ ] problem
with anybody unbelievable
I don't know what to say you know what
since I don't know who's Jackie Bradley
jr. or JD Martinez one of them said
after game three that I was at can't
believe I was at the game he said I've
never seen a tape a team yet just get
punched in the face and then just get up
like nothing happened like this team
something like that I know I'm
butchering it but it was just perfect
they were just never out of it I have
not seen a team score this many [ __ ]
runs with two outs B down this much
since the 1998 New York Yankees which is
probably the best team I've ever seen
the only other team in my lifetime and I
vaguely remember seeing them was maybe
the Big Red Machine I mean that team
that team was [ __ ] incredible that
was just another team that was just like
they would just stacked all right you
know what I'm lying a little bit that
that anyways congratulations to the
Dodgers manatees as Christ another great
season he just came up short all I can
tell you having been through that you
know it just makes it all the more
sweeter when you finally win it but uh
you know so we went to Game three what a
[ __ ] great stadium by the way and not
only is a great stadium that the Dodgers
have like the stadium just considering
when it was built and there was so many
of those soulless cookie cutter baseball
stadiums that they made they were
multi-purpose basically all of them was
to design so you could play football and
baseball back there a very like
forward-thinking money-saving
environmentally friendly thing that we
did and then we all decided like you
know what [ __ ] these stadiums their old
wife fix them up I don't understand why
you just can't fix them up they're made
out of metal and concrete they're not
going anywhere that's like any [ __ ]
car you have the
[ __ ] engine block is made out of
steel as long as you take care of it
it's gonna it's gonna run forever
everybody just throws [ __ ] out
so they knocked down all of these
[ __ ] stadiums and then rebuild not at
one but two more stadiums I want my own
Stadium I don't want to share although
you know I did Boomer Esiason show
boomer in and it was a Gino and he was
talking about what it was like to play
for the since the Cincinnati Bengals in
the same in Riverfront Stadium
he said doubt least to cover a home
plate with a piece of wood and then just
threw astroturf on top of it so if you
got tackled on it basically it's like
you laid it on somebody's tree fort so I
guess you know maybe that's the reason
but I would what I thought they could
have come up with some sort of
technology where they didn't have to
[ __ ] that was just basically because it
was astroturf right I don't know I don't
pretend to understand but me and my
buddies we went to Game three and I
didn't wear any red sock [ __ ] still
almost got into a fight [ __ ] West
Coast still almost got into a fight
un-fuckin'-believable you know there was
like what killed me was we went to the
game and there was so many empty seats
because StubHub just gouged the [ __ ] out
of everything like seven on a buck stop
I was at the top of Stadium those
tickets were over $700 and you know I
guess StubHub was content to be like
well you know we'll make it four times
the [ __ ] face value of the ticket
what what what do we give a [ __ ] if
every you know three out of every four
seats is empty almost you know it wasn't
that bad but there were big giant swaths
of [ __ ] rows that were just nobody
was there from the bottom all the way up
to the top and you know people
flat-screen TVs they don't need that
[ __ ] they don't come home they'll see
the [ __ ] replay they'll know the
pitch count they'll you know all of that
[ __ ] rather than being like me trying to
figure out the scoreboard with my [ __ ]
up eyes at this point so anyways my
buddy you know he was having a few beers
and he when he was finishing he's just
setting up in the row behind us that was
like basically empty
it was a guy behind there and you know
all you had to say was hey guys do you
mind just keeping your empties on you in
your robe just cuz you know meaning the
kid boy from the kid won't try to get by
here and sorry dude no problem that's
how would have gone down but instead
because he's a West Coast guy you know
there's so [ __ ] laid-back out here he
immediately just says to my buddy good
this is how he enters the conversation
he goes he's like hey buddy is there
something wrong with the underneath here
chair Fred turns around looks at him
immediate with that look on his face
like wow about ready to get to a fight
he's like what he goes there's something
wrong with the underneath partying chair
and he's like no he goes why don't you
put your empties there I go there was
nobody sit back and then it [ __ ] in
in like literally like [ __ ] flash
paper escalates to this level so I'm
sitting there so I just go you know I've
been out here long enough I'm a veteran
like I know this is gonna happen like
you could literally go to the game
[ __ ] dress like Jesus or Santa Claus
whatever the [ __ ] you're into and still
somebody's gonna be like you know hey
[ __ ] it uh hey whitey you think you
cannot have your [ __ ] beard blowing
over your shoulder block and half the
[ __ ] feel like something's gonna
happen hey Santa why she's sooo red what
are you a [ __ ] Cardinals fan you know
and all of a sudden you're into it so I
just turn around looked at both two
magical ladies ladies ladies which
usually diffuses it somebody saying
ladies all right then you realize I got
alright I'm acting like I got a [ __ ]
tampon on right like oh we're at the
World Series Game four how come out
let's have a good time right so I go to
shake the guy's hand behind me and he
leaves me hanging so now I'm [ __ ] mad
I don't say anything to the guy and then
I just just [ __ ] sit up so we sit
down and then I for [ __ ] hitting and
loudly talking about what the level of
[ __ ] [ __ ] fans [ __ ] [ __ ]
fans that are out here on the [ __ ]
west coast it's just like they go to the
game to get into a fight it's just like
so after an inning half of that I'm like
dude do you really want to keep doing
this it's like no I don't so I get up I
go down to get a beer and I'm coming
back and I'm walking up the aisle this
[ __ ] guy
it's sitting at mean-mugging me now this
guy he's got to be like [ __ ] 50
pounds over [ __ ] weight there's four
of us there's one of him not granted
he's in the row behind us I guess maybe
he could fall on us and do some [ __ ]
damage but if we wanted to we all could
probably could have picked him up and
thrown him over we were the second to
last row literally just thrown him off
the back of the [ __ ] stadium all
right and when you're dealing with
people from Boston that isn't that is a
there's a chance that there's that level
of [ __ ] anger involved it wasn't us
but I'm just saying and this guy could
give a [ __ ] so he's [ __ ] staring at
me as I'm walking up he's with his wife
and kid and he's [ __ ] staring at us
like like [ __ ] William Wallace
staring at me I should say as I'm coming
up so I'm literally my eyes are [ __ ]
bad at this point so Mike is this guy
staring at me
so when you're [ __ ] old you got to
either squint or you kind of look away
and then look at that look back at
something so I had to look away to focus
something else and then I look back at
him I'm like yeah he is staring at me
and I just looked away so he probably
thought that was a moment of weakness so
now he's probably there it is he's going
next too hard with his face now sweat it
God so he just got up there and I don't
know what happened all of the anger all
it should have just went away I was just
like buddy we really gonna do this man
come on I respect the Dodgers I respect
you once Ron I apologize for that stuff
so I go to so I see his face finally
relax I go to fist bump the guy he's so
[ __ ] macho he can't even like stick
his hand he makes the fist but he has
his hand still near his body it's like
my daughter when I when I first like was
like teaching her how to wave and she
wouldn't like lift her hand her arm up
she would just like open and close her
hand while it just rested on her leg it
was like adorable but with this guy it
was just so I don't know what it was it
was just like wow this guy's got a lot
of pain I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened to say fist bump long story
short by the end of the game even though
his Dodgers are losing we're like
friends or friendly anyways defuse the
whole [ __ ] thing a Mayank my angry
[ __ ] Italian Boston guy and what he's
like dude how the [ __ ] did you do that
how to find I just said to him I was
just like do I go I'm [ __ ] done with
it
I'm done I'm not I'm not [ __ ] doing
this anymore I'm not gonna [ __ ] go to
a [ __ ] baseball game and then almost
getting as a 50 year old bald [ __ ]
dude almost get into a fight over an
empty [ __ ] Bud Light beer can and
where it was placed within this concrete
structure I'm John I'm just not I'm not
[ __ ] doing it anymore right
I had already almost gotten into a fight
with my wife and I diffused that because
we had pregame at my house and evidently
my wife didn't feel like she was invited
I don't know why we were in the house
she's always been invited but what had
you know what happened I came off the
road and I was under the gun where I
didn't have a lot of time between
getting back to the house giving her a
hug and a kiss checking in with my kid
and then making sure I had beer for
people coming over to go to the game
because the game starts at 5:00 and I
didn't get back from Phoenix until uh
you know one o'clock didn't get home
till like 2:00 right so you know they're
coming home they're coming back I'm
sorry I got home but like 1:00 1:00
o'clock and my friends are coming over
at 2:00 so I barely hugged and kissed my
wife and then asked her to go out and uh
and get some beer for the guys you know
which is something I never do I usually
handle everything you know she's always
got the honey-do list for me but I never
have anything for her so I thinking can
you uh get some beers and she's looking
at me like I just act as her if she
could [ __ ] walk on water or something
so a half hour goes by and I'm looking
at my are you gonna go out and get the
beer and she goes are you serious I
didn't know you were being serious I was
like yeah being serious like why would I
say that is a joke and she goes well cuz
you know I'm I'm just sort of sitting
here you know hanging out and [ __ ]
you know it's one it's one of those you
know it's just one of those things in a
relationship where it like one person is
gonna ask somebody else to do something
that they never do themselves or vice
versa or something like that so I don't
know she couldn't get a [ __ ] head
around so then she goes and she gets the
beer
you know she pulls up and of course when
she pulls up she's like can you come out
here and help me bring the beer in
because that's what the [ __ ] they can
never just [ __ ] do something for they
still got to drag you in right and I
missed that text so my friends went out
and helped her out and then she was
[ __ ] pissed at me or whatever so
we're driving to the game and she's like
texting me about what a jerk I am
so I [ __ ] defuse that I go to the
[ __ ] game i defuse the fat [ __ ]
behind us that's all I did the whole
[ __ ] day defuse and [ __ ] as I watched
the Red Sox then go down you know four
to nothing and after that crazy [ __ ]
game in Game three where we used our
starting you know game for picture I
mean what I mean how great a game did
what's-his-face Bueller pitch I feel
like people forgot about that with the
Dodgers winning was all about that guy
hitting the home run I apologize I got a
kid now I don't know anybody's [ __ ]
names anymore
I watched the games while I [ __ ]
switch back and forth between the game
and puppy-dog pass every time I switched
from puppy-dog pals back to the game my
daughter just points at the TV and goes
oh Jorgen I got a mic just a second Mimi
Mao Mimi Mao it sounds like she's
speaking like Chinese or something she's
saying it Minnie Mouse
Mimi Mao me me me me me moe
anyways so I don't even know who hit the
[ __ ] homerun the whole thing was such
a blur I've been so goddamn busy
somebody hit a [ __ ] home run for the
Red Sox to make it three to nothing I
mean four to three then we scored
another run then we [ __ ] loaded them
up and then that holy analytic [ __ ] that
taking guys out that are doing a good
job I don't [ __ ] understand
I mean analytics when in those
situations sometimes I swear to god it's
like it's like baseballs version of the
[ __ ] prevent defense where like I am
sure on paper this [ __ ] makes sense
but why you know stop watching the
[ __ ] pitch count what is this guy
doing to the opposite team right now
he sees he's [ __ ] killing him but
he's up to 27 pitches and the
juxtaposition for his ball and socket
joint out [ __ ] shoulder to his his
his jugular we need to take him out
during the 28th and I had a [ __ ]
pitch right there doing that [ __ ] so
anyways we end up coming back I think we
won that we were winning the game like 9
to 4 and then Kimbrel comes in you know
you know how he closes the game he lets
up a co home run and a [ __ ] double you
know I know he's coming off an injury
god bless the guy whatever but he scared
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me and we won
the game and then it was great I got to
walk onto the state I didn't any problem
I shook the guy's hand behind me and you
know I know I saw a bunch of people
wearing red socks [ __ ] there I guess
what I'm just too old to do it and my
favorite [ __ ] part about going to an
opposing team Stadium rooting for the
other team is when I'm not wearing my
own gear and I go into the bathroom and
I don't have to worry that five guys are
gonna push me in the back when I go to
take a [ __ ] piss you don't I mean cuz
their team's losing and the the the
[ __ ] bathroom with all of that
porcelain all of that tile and none of
that none of the [ __ ] security
there's urine on the floor it's just the
[ __ ] worst and that's that's where it
goes down and to just be able to walk in
there and just not have a [ __ ]
problem I wasn't being a dick when the
Red Sox were scoring runs
I was definitely cheering but I did it
in a respectful way I didn't do that
[ __ ] I always see that when I'm watching
games you know any game any game i watch
and i'll see the opposing team score
when they cut to the crowd you'll always
see one douchebag not only standing up
wearing [ __ ] everything he could
possibly be wearing for the other team
he's turning around facing the crowd you
know like he's [ __ ] you know Steven
Seagal and marked for death and he's
gonna beat up a whole [ __ ] section
though he's some [ __ ] fat bloated
drunk jackass and every time I see it I
always just think like somebody should
beat the [ __ ] out of that guy somebody
shouldn't but you know you never watch
the Discovery Channel you don't know how
nature works like what you have just no
[ __ ] I don't know
what no uh no respect for like your own
well-being like why the what why the
[ __ ] would you do that so anyways that's
just not how I did it so then I got home
and it was late at night and we were
just sitting there like can you [ __ ]
believe this [ __ ] it was like we were
down for two nothing I wasn't even
nervous because I was thinking even if
the Dodgers tied this series up we're
still gonna win it like that's how much
this is psychology I'm talking about the
[ __ ] Boston Red Sox I never thought I
would have this feeling about it I just
knew these guys were gonna come back I
didn't think it was gonna happen in that
game and we won that game and I just
couldn't [ __ ] believe it and I didn't
talk one ounce of [ __ ] [ __ ]
none of that stuff I just you know I
wanted my team to win they won that was
good enough for me I don't need to
[ __ ] start walking around being a
[ __ ] about it but like that's really it
just really is just sort of part of the
sports culture and what's funny is is
how people don't see that their own fans
of their team do it too like I know when
the Red Sox are playing New York New
York for whatever stupid [ __ ] reason
in the locker room after we wanted it
was all these Yankee fans going over
real clear so you could tell you this
with the Yogi's with last thing we'll be
doing is thinking about the Red Sox it's
like yeah you will be yes you will be
because you took the time to go on
Twitter to [ __ ] comment on that you
took the time to find out about it you
were obviously on the Red Sox threads to
see it you know and then they all real
classy Boston like and just like and
you're really forgetting that your fan
base threw a beer in the face of our
reliever as he came out of the bullpen
you're gonna forget you chanted 1918 at
[ __ ] old ladies if they had a Red Sox
hat on for the better part of a [ __ ]
century man come on grow the [ __ ] up
it's not something I would do I think
it's dumb to do that because it just you
know gives the other team more incentive
or whatever but uh personally speaking
all I give a [ __ ] about is my team and
like now my other big thing is I'd love
to see the Red Sox win it again so then
we would be in double digits in
Champions
championships in two different
professional sports basketball and and
in baseball and I think we would be the
first city that ever did that
not to mention here's another stat if
you're into [ __ ] stats I also believe
that the Red Sox are the first
professional sports franchise to win a
championship the same year in two
different centuries huh
am I going [ __ ] Billy ball on you
hear a little nerd enough for you and
lastly but not leastly I can't remember
cuz I had to start this podcast again
cuz my record record was filled up if I
didn't I don't give a [ __ ] I apologize
so again my apologies to David Price
Jesus Christ I could not have been more
wrong and there's gonna be a bunch of
people out there being like dude I
[ __ ] said it I knew it I never
doubted that guy about they're full of
[ __ ] you're maybe you're not but I did i
100% thought I actually thought we
weren't gonna win it and the problem was
gonna be that David Price was a headcase
couldn't beat the Yankees couldn't win
the big game couldn't win [ __ ] in
October i 100% thought that and i was
like you know you need the 1-2 punch you
need you know you need to monster shut
it down pitchers to win a seven-game
series now that's how it is with all the
free agents seemingly piling on six
different teams and I was 100% wrong I
actually thought you know price should
have been the MVP considering all of
that [ __ ] chatter that was in his ear
and considering you know he won both his
starts he came in during the pitch
relief and heat up some innings and he
just he just crushed it and couldn't be
more happy for that guy it could be more
happy that I was 100% wrong 100 percent
wrong and I loved his when his press
conference afterwards when he was going
you know you guys had that card on me
and you played it you played it well but
you don't have it anymore he goes I have
the trump card and it feels great and I
just wish one of those sports writers in
there you know they never [ __ ] own up
when they're [ __ ] wrong you know
aren't at least not enough they should
one of them should have been like hey
David I'll feel how good
it's filled to stare at all of us who
[ __ ] doubted you and wrote all that
bad [ __ ] about you myself included you
know why don't they ever say that you
know so anyways I don't know but get
back to that stuff I would not have
played New York New York I would not it
like why would you do that you [ __ ]
kick the Yankees ass you know you got to
be above that [ __ ] but I guess there's
always that stuff you go to a Rangers
game and the range is still chant Potvin
sucks
I go to an avalanche game but a dead red
wedge suck you just have your [ __ ]
rival and I guess I understand it
because Yankee fans were such [ __ ] for
so goddamn long I guess I understand it
but uh I'm only I'm always I always
think it's way better to score the
touchdown and just hand the ball to the
ref you do some stupid dance all it does
is [ __ ] make the guy covering you I
don't know just want to [ __ ] play
that much harder if you just do it like
it wasn't [ __ ] I just feel like it's
just way more defeating but what do I
know
you know moons last time Bill you played
a game in [ __ ] gym class I'm trying
to think the last time I played other
than hockey and played hockey in three
years so I hurt my back and then I had a
kid so I'm my hockey stuff has been
sitting there every time I walk by is
like I have not I remember September of
2015 I haven't skated in three [ __ ]
years
pathetic but anyways so congratulations
to the Red Sox congratulations to the
Dodgers man I know [ __ ] brutal but it
will be all the more sweeter when you
finally push through and you know
getting past all this fans [ __ ] like I
really do like all of those
organizations that we played including
the [ __ ] Yankees I mean you can't get
mad the most successful you know you
can't be a fan of sports in that respect
what the [ __ ] they've done any with that
that's it I'm done talking about it
the Patriots got the bills tonight they
did Lewis Hamilton wrap it up yesterday
they I imagine he [ __ ] he's always on
the podium I think all I needed to do
was just get into like
worth a fifth-place and he would have
had it wrapped up let's see Lewis
Hamilton oh by the way thank you to
everybody that came out to why does it
always go to how come it always goes to
Wikipedia is that because I always go to
Wikipedia would it already be up there
when 71 minutes of the Delawares
championships
yep II just want it 2018 he won it again
congratulations congratulations so Lewis
Hamilton wins the f1 championship and
Mike Marquez
won the MotoGP race and I want to thank
everybody that has helped me along as
I've gotten into both of those sports
and I'm absolutely obsessed with them
although I you know like I said with the
Kido
I don't have as much time to watch them
the way I want to but they are on my DVR
was it was at Brazil I was Mexico that's
one of my favorite races where they
drive through the old baseball stadium
I might go to that one next year who
knows who knows all I know is it's
Halloween this weekend I'm in town and
we're having this little kid Halloween
party you know you know nightclubs are
like you know 21 and older I think this
is like it's like 18 months and under so
it's gonna be a bunch of little kids
running around it's gonna be hilarious
my wife is like totally decked out the
house and everything oh by the way when
I came home after the game she was still
upset with me and I didn't know that she
was still up so we were outside yet
smoke good cigars and [ __ ] and she
texted me she's like where are you Mike
I'm downstairs the back porch and she
got all [ __ ] mad at me like she
wasn't invited so I went upstairs and I
got tight she was so trying to have a
fight with me I just wouldn't have a
fight it was like listen I don't want to
fight with you just tell me what the
problem is I love you you're awesome I
love you you love me
we're not going anywhere I don't go to
bed angry at you what did I do that
upset you and like how can we how can we
work this out and just you know stop
yelling at each other I don't want to
yell you she's just fine I don't care
she had to go through that you know for
once she was being the baby you know
so that's my new thing I'm just I I
don't know what happened somewhere in
that Dodger game
I want to thank that guy who's standing
behind me the absurdity of it he just
finally hit me it's just like I'm not
[ __ ] doing I'm just not doing this
anymore
Jesus Christ I just saw a [ __ ] letter
for this week I'm copying and pasting it
right now
it just said girlfriend wants to bang my
brother now that debt just I refuse to
believe that that's a true thing but
I'll read that in a minute here I got to
do the advertising it was probably not a
good thing to tease right before I'm
going to read advertising advertisements
alright where the hell is it
Oh endo Chino talk about stressful talk
about you should say how stressful it is
knowing you have to go to an event in a
suit that doesn't fit oh yeah that's the
worst I had to go to wait the reason why
I didn't see any a-game our clinching
Red Sox game yet because I had to go to
a wedding and we had the after the
after-party for season three of efforts
for family we had a great time we
actually went bowling and so I kind of
do like double duty last night I was
watching that whole thing on my phone
but anyways I love going to weddings now
now that I'm married and I have a kid
it's like all the pressures over I did
it okay I committed to somebody I
procreated you know [ __ ] off I imagine
it's the same feeling David Price has
right now okay I did it I got a ring go
[ __ ] yourself I am the David Price of
wedding wedding guests right now anyways
what it was Indo Chino right indochina
here's how it works
visit a stylist at our showroom and have
them take your measurements personally
or measure at home yourself and shop
online in Indo Chino comm choose your
fabric inside and out choose your design
customizations submit your measurements
with your choices relax while your suit
gets professionally tailored and mailed
to you in a couple of weeks call to
action this is mandatory alright this
week my listeners can get any premium in
no
she don't suit for just three and fifty
nine dollars at Indochina calm when
entering BRR at checkout
that's fifty percent off the regular
price for a made-to-measure premium suit
plus shipping is free
that's endo keno calm promo code bar for
any premium suit for just three and
fifty nine dollars and free shipping
incredible deal for a premium
made-to-measure suit Indochina are also
expanding into casual clothing your
made-to-measure chinos will quickly
become your go-to pant pairing as easily
with suit jackets as they do with the
sweater and they'll be good oh my god
they go with the [ __ ] suit jacket and
a sweater that's totally my wheelhouse
right now that's the age group almond
start wearing sport coats on [ __ ]
stage I'm at that age you know cover up
my [ __ ] the mistakes I've made it the
[ __ ] kitchen counter all right zip
recruiter that's actually not true I'm
actually in good shape right now but you
know it's always good to have a big
sport coat hanging around for you if
you're going through your fat months you
know the holidays anyway zip recruiting
you know what's not smart job sites that
overwhelm you with tons of the wrong
resumes but do you know what is smart
zip recruiter dot-com slash bar
unlike other jobs sites zip recruiter
doesn't wait for candidates to find you
all zip finds them for you it's powerful
matching technology scans thousands of
resumes identifies people with the right
skills education and experience for your
job an activity actively sorry invites
them to apply so you get qualified
candidates fast no more sorting through
the wrong resumes no more waiting for
the right candidates to apply it's no
wonder that zip recruit isn't is rated
number one by employers in the u.s. this
rating comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over 1000 reviews ok look at
them they're backing it up a little
footnotes there right now my listeners
can try zip for free at the exclusive
web address zip recruit calm slash birth
at zip recruited calm slash bar Hey
zip calm / / zi PR EC Rui ter calm the
smartest way - hyah oh look who's here
what do you got three more let's break
this up let's read some [ __ ] let's
read some [ __ ] questions here let's
read some questions here then when I get
off this thing yeah I got to go do the
honey the honey do list right and you
know what I'm gonna do it with everybody
I'm gonna do it with the [ __ ] smile
on my face and I'm not gonna yeah I'm
done dude I am done fighting I've had
I'm just gonna keep saying it out loud
so I make it a real thing I'm done with
it what is the [ __ ] problem what I
really need to say I'm sorry what is the
problem but I the only place I've
graduated to right now is what is the
[ __ ] problem all right
if I can take the [ __ ] out of there get
some of the angry tone out of my voice I
think I'll be doing even better all
right
granted I'll probably run out of
material but that's beside the point
speaking of material if you guys here to
patreon patreon announcement here why by
popular demand people have been asking
for more content where they can donate
etc all right the what why what and all
of this [ __ ] all right I have a new I'm
gonna have I'm launching a patreon page
it's gonna go live on November 5th all
right and this is what you're gonna be
get all this extra content all right
patreon spell PA Treo n you're gonna get
two episodes of the uninformed podcast
with me and all Joey roses I'm bringing
it back you get extra video content
sitio tour city tours backstage footage
helicopter rides whatever the [ __ ] I'm
doing how much is it it's 5 bucks a
month Jesus Christ lay off on a couple
of [ __ ] cartons of eggs and you got
yourself all this other content all
right November's content will go live
November 5th I have a live video podcast
it's a live podcast from Phoenix that
was a good podcast - full video of this
show as well
as downloads to mp3 two episodes of
uninformed and I'm gonna be doing a
bunch of other [ __ ] you know puss on
behind the scenes [ __ ] at my shows and
all that type of stuff you know it's
funny they say that I have a patreon
page and they don't even tell me
I guess you go to patreon and you just
try to look up my name whatever I'll
keep promoting I'll promote it and again
speaking of which please watch on what
is it this week November 3rd Paul virzi
stand-up special on Comedy Central is
coming out and it was done by my my
company that I started with al Madrigal
all things comedy this is our first
special that is coming out we're very
excited and it would be you it would be
huge
this Thursday night if you guys could
say what it is no no that's not Thursday
night look at the run things Sunday
night sunday sunday wah-wah-wah-wah-wah
no that's the wrong one - why is it in
May I swear to God don't it don't even
listen to me here we go I'm sorry this
Saturday night November 3rd
Paul Versys stand-up special on Comedy
Central I think it comes on at midnight
yeah I'm just really proud of them this
is just one of these guys who should
have got a special a long time ago and
did not and with the company that I
started with al Madrigal ad matter
Madrigal being the driving force behind
it we were able to get ourselves in
position we actually made a deal with
Comedy Central and we're producing four
one-hour specials for them for the next
year this is the first one and we're
going to pick in all these comics that
we love and so please check that out if
you can alright let's let's read let's
read a little question here Corvette a
Billy Beane ballbag need advice on a car
I would love to purchase next year I'm
looking to try at trying to get a c7
Corvette the latest model Corvettes a c7
oh okay or is that the bought is that
the body type Oh what do you know look
at that I can't [ __ ] hear myself what
just happened
gravity happened now I got to sit there
and literally hold this thing I
literally got my thumb down on the
connection here like one of those bad
action movies where the guy comes
walking and going if I take my thumb off
this pig we all go up I gotta do that
for the rest of the podcast evidently so
anyway so I imagine that's [ __ ] go to
a Radio Shack and just buy what the [ __ ]
you need instead of dealing with this
every week [ __ ] [ __ ] hey you know
what I'm also done getting mad at
inanimate objects Joe DeRosa had a great
bit about that
and I remember listening to it going you
know what I really should learn how to
do that and I haven't and as far as I
can tell he hasn't learned how to not do
it either anyways it's the latest model
of Corvettes I'm currently 23 years old
married to an absolute [ __ ] gem have
a house with her and pay for everything
we want slash half dude you [ __ ]
killing it not trying to pay Pat myself
on the back but I'm happy with where I
am in life anyways do you think it would
be good a dumb idea to get a Corvette
next year and I'm going to be a little
[ __ ] and get an automatic I want to be
able to have my mom drive it since
that's her dream car otherwise I would
just get a manual anyways don't go [ __ ]
yourself and keep on keepin on dude if
you know you're married to a gem and
you're living within your means if you
can afford to get a Corvette get a
Corvette you know here's the deal I
don't if they make it in a stick still
it seems like everything is just the
paddle shifting if you still can get it
in a stick and maybe a great way to
teach your mom how to drive a stick she
grinds the gears on your brand new
Corvette probably a dumb idea sounded
good in my head until I [ __ ] said that
although I tell you one of the big
things that in the future that I want to
do with my daughters I want to teach you
how to drive my truck which is three on
the column and I think that yeah how
badass will that be that she you know
that someone born in 2017 will know how
to drive a 1968 Ford f100 and she's a
lady
yeah my kid's gonna be a badass she's
gonna know how to do [ __ ] do you think
everybody's [ __ ] pretty girls sitting
at the bar like I'm just gonna pretend I
don't know thing anyways yeah I think
that's a great idea if you want a gay
you know if you know it seems like
you're kind of also doing it for your
mom which is a great thing and cars you
know I don't know when people are like
car people it really means a lot when
they they get the one that they've
always wanted you know I don't know I've
bought I bought a car you know I bought
the car my wife wanted and I saw the
look on her face so I can imagine you
know and that's the woman that I married
so I know what that feeling is life I
can't imagine if you get it for your mom
and you're able to pay her back like
that yeah absolutely I would [ __ ] do
that why don't you go buy a [ __ ] box
in the meantime that's a stick and go
teach your mom how to drive drive a
drive a standard transmission be great
together time you'll laugh your asses
off and you know and that's great for
you know somebody who's older to learn
something new it's a lot of options here
man they're all good glad your life is
in that place that that email actually
made made me happy believe it or not
somebody killing it like that see that I
got a good hat all right girlfriend
wants to bang my brother ah we I teased
this earlier in the podcast girlfriend
wants to bang my brother Jesus Christ I
would love to hear Joel Olsteen read
this [ __ ] thing I mean Jesus wants
your girlfriend to bang your brother hey
Bill I'm sure this happens this has
happened to you before
eyes that along a roundabout way of
saying that I'm not a good-looking guy
but how should I handle my girlfriend
wanting to bang my brother more than me
thoughts she said it three times in one
night what why are you still in this
relationship would you still be in the
relationship if you said that about our
set
hey listen sweetheart not to say you
don't have a nice rack but like I mean
you got to agree with me I mean your
sisters tits are ridiculous
do you now bad I want to stick my dick
between the two of them you know what
what anyways she said it in one night
three times in one night
and that he is better looking etc so
she's either going to [ __ ] him or she's
just trying to get under my skin I told
her after the third time to go [ __ ] him
then and she tried to act like I was an
[ __ ] yes of course
of course she did I feel like this
crossed a line and it's all I can think
about oh dude I got to tell you
something right now
not only do you say that you [ __ ]
dumper
dude dude for her to [ __ ] say that to
you is so out of line and that is just
the tip of the [ __ ] iceberg of the
mind games of a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
this is gonna play with somebody all
right dump this person this is the thing
she's gonna actually [ __ ] respect you
because she obviously doesn't respect
you enough that she's saying that [ __ ]
to you so if you [ __ ] dump her
you know what's gonna actually make her
want to do is [ __ ] you more and this is
what you do this is the Jedi level you
know what when she wants to [ __ ] you
more after that you know what you do yet
dun dun dun it's over that's one of
those things like I don't know what kind
of a [ __ ] jerk-off you think I am
like that that's basically what she's
saying either she thinks you're a
[ __ ] jerk-off and you have to show
her that you're not
I would dump her and then that is
[ __ ] it that is [ __ ] it and when
she [ __ ] does all of those women
manipulating things and [ __ ] turns on
the sex vibe and all that dude you
[ __ ] you like oh nothing you give her
nothing
that's it I need to read the rest of
this I will though if it was a friend of
mine she thought was more attractive I
wouldn't care you should care
she shouldn't be saying that dude this
is this is what you don't [ __ ] say
that
let me ask you this could you do any of
this to her could you say that one of
her girlfriends is more attractive than
her three times in one night anyways he
said but I hate the fact it's my
bald-headed [ __ ] of a brother what
should I do anything I think about I get
more angry
thanks and wear a hat next I like are
you taking your anger out on me yeah
dude you're dating somebody that has
crossed a line that you're not gonna be
able to get past okay Pass sorry I
really gotta save my voice dude I've
been screaming and yelling every weekend
doing my act and been watching the Red
Sox through the playoffs so I apologize
for my I think I'm going through puberty
here yeah dude that is a no [ __ ]
brainer you know just dumped her and
it's nothing don't tell your older
brother or your younger brother whoever
your brother is don't don't tell your
brother why you dumped him because one
day he's gonna get drunk he's gonna
bring it up and then you know like an
[ __ ] and then you guys are gonna get
into a fight okay it's all because of
this this [ __ ] who is trying is driving
a wedge into your family this is this is
the kind of person you're gonna bring
this person to your family tree huh
you're gonna dump your [ __ ] seed into
that I don't think you are walk away
walk away and you know what dude you got
off [ __ ] easy if you dump this woman
right now you and you got off [ __ ]
easy Jesus Christ
god bless the poor [ __ ] bastard that
she's gonna [ __ ] marry right there
anyways
dear hillbilly buck-toothed I'm in a bit
of a pickle I'm twenty three lattes a
lot a lot of emails from 23 year olds
this week evidently 23 year olds I
haven't have a little difficult [ __ ]
time here dear hillbilly buck-toothed
I'm a bit of a M in a bit of a pickle
I'm 23 and want to break up with my
girlfriend of
two years we're long-distance I'm a Kiwi
she's a Yank
what's a Kiwi again is that [ __ ] New
Zealand my candy I can't even keep up
anyways I know I got to look it up I
don't want you guys to sound ignorant
like me there we go
Kiwi people Wikipedia once again Kiwi is
a nickname used for internationally for
people from New Zealand as well as being
relatively common self-reference unlike
many demographic leyva its uses is not
considered offensive rather it's
generally view as a symbol of Pride and
endearment from for the people of New
Zealand the name derives from the Kiwi a
native flightless bird which is a
national symbol of New Zealand it's a
flightless bird meaning you guys aren't
leaving the island is that what it is
until the first world war the Kiwi
represented the country and not the
people however by 1917 New Zealanders
were being called Kiwis supplanting
other nicknames so that's cool it's
great that eventually it didn't become
offensive usually after a while it does
are you saying that my dreams will never
take anyways I'm a Kiwi eat she's a Yank
sure blocker on face ok
I'm 23 and want to break up with my
girlfriend of two years okay well you
just sit down you just say listen we
have to talk all right this is something
no I wish somebody just told me this is
what you saying you just sit down to see
honey listen we have to talk is
something wrong and then you just say
yes I'm just I'm not happy okay I don't
think you're a bad person or anything
but I'm just this just doesn't feel
right you know it feels right in that I
like you but it doesn't feel like I like
you to the point that I'm gonna marry
you and then they just stop talking and
it's it and then she'll start [ __ ]
crying and blah blah blah and she's
crying because she's sad
and that is a normal emotion and you
have to be comfortable with that and
just you just said it no I did you say
you know and I I think we need to end
this relationship now I think and we
need to end this relationship that's it
you said it I'm not happy I'm not
feeling like you're the person I'm gonna
marry we need to end this relationship
boom boom boom
we need to talk I'm not happy yeah you
just [ __ ] that's it and you just get
it all out and it's gonna be another two
[ __ ] hours but you don't waver you
don't go back and then then you're out
that's it
and then you anyways he says sure block
her on blocker on Facebook and other
social medias we used to correspond the
problem is she has a lot of filthy nudes
of mine I've sent her over the past few
years needless to say I have my fair
share of hers all right well that's a
stalemate then I'm worried she'll
distribute them maliciously in revenge
for breaking it off with her she's that
kind of spiteful trust me any advice
other than hindsight thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself you're just gonna have to man
up and do it dude you know and if the
world's gonna see a dick for a couple
days then so be it that's it that's it
all right and I'm actually happy for you
because who wants to be who would want
to marry a spiteful person because she
would have done that to you if you
stayed with her in other areas you're
not happy get the [ __ ] out of it and
then you're hindsight stop sending dick
pics to people you know I don't know
that's that's how I believe that what do
you [ __ ] laying there like Burt
Reynolds and Playgirl except you weren't
covering your junk I don't understand
women cuz they're beautiful I just don't
understand I don't understand understand
guys doing that now you like these dick
and balls up hanging off here
a naked guy it's like literally it looks
like it's like a design flaw you know
women are all curvy smooth and
aerodynamic you know other went to the
point other women can look at other
naked women be like oh my god she's
beautiful you know what I mean a naked
guy yeah you [ __ ] this [ __ ] hanging
off cover it up dilemma
hey bill I'm writing in as another
female listener going on six years now
love your work and I'm hoping you can
help me decide something all right I
love when the ladies write in I'm 18
just turned 18 all right and I've been
working at an estate firm for three
years look at you
good for you I don't know what that is
but that sounds impressive to me I'm a
sophomore in college
how are you only 18 years old doing all
this stuff you like in advanced classes
most people who could play the cello
when you were three I'm on a soft I'm a
sophomore in college pursuing a criminal
degree then going on to law school I've
always wanted to be a criminal defense
attorney well looking to make that
happen by the time you're like 21
anyways however the lady I work for who
runs the estate firm once to pass the
firm to me but I never intended to
pursue a career in a state law by
dilemma seems to be I can't decide
whether I should accept this
overwhelmingly kind offer of the estate
firm ready for me when I graduate law
school or start from scratch at the
bottom in criminal law the estate firm
would need some work but all in all is a
successful business from listening to
your story of how you are a self-made
man I would assume you would say pick
criminal if that's what you've always
wanted but who in their right mind turns
down a firm that's wrapped and ready
with their name on it looking forward to
your insight you make rush hour drives
bearable thanks and kindly go [ __ ]
yourself from another broad all right
Jesus Christ is this like the coolest
person ever she's 18 she's crushing it
listen
you're an amazingly successful person
for 18 years of age and I would look at
it like this estate firm it's just you
know it's like when Columbus was sailing
across the ocean before he saw land it
was a couple of tree branches so that's
what's coming here you're seeing that
your big things coming you definitely
got do what the [ __ ] you want to do I
think you'll regret way more not trying
to be in the part of law that you wanted
to be in then walking away from some
money because you know you know the
money the money makes money makes you
like relaxed as far as like you can pay
your bills and [ __ ] like that but it
doesn't do anything for like your soul
or your heart you know what I mean your
passions it just doesn't unless your
passion is you love [ __ ] money you
know whatever the [ __ ] that is so yeah I
would definitely just stay on the track
that you're on and you know just tell
the person I'm obviously ridiculously
flattered but you know my dream since
I've been little has been to be a
criminal defense attorney that's the
direction that's the part of law I want
to be in and I just know that I would
have this regret while I ran your state
firm and your estate firm deserves
somebody that has the same level of
passion for state law as I do for
criminal law and there you said it and
the person is going to sit down they're
gonna start crying no kidding you know
it's like really like this should be a
course on how to break up with somebody
and then also how to have confrontations
like this anywhere from the fat guy yet
yeah behind you at a baseball game to
somebody's offering you something that
nobody would say no to but your your
heart is saying I can't do this and
that's it and the thing about it is is
what you have to learn is a young person
is you have to learn the this this is
one of the biggest biggest skills in
life is learning how to have productive
confrontation all right where you
express what you want and you get what
you want or at the very least you stayed
you want if you're not getting what you
want you walk but you don't do it
there's no name-calling there's no
raising of voices and even if the other
person goes there you don't match their
energy you just let them yell and stuff
like that and you just stay calm they
should I don't know I'm sure somebody's
doing that out there but they just don't
do it enough and you know I turned a
corner the other night with my wife were
you know I didn't go to where her energy
was I understood why she was upset with
me and I told her she was right you are
right I didn't come home and ask you how
you were doing you're right I apologize
for that I'll work on that but like I
don't want to yell it yeah I love you
that's it and what the [ __ ] is somebody
gonna do with that I don't give a [ __ ]
that you love me they just sound stupid
and women fortunately enough a rational
enough that you can kind of talk them
down you know we're guys you know we're
like I don't want to deal with my
emotions you know you just go for a
[ __ ] buy the play new thing that I go
I go for a walk you know I stay go go go
for a walk I go out to my garage I play
drums a couple of Pantera songs and I've
just lost myself in that and then I come
back and I can just sit you know it's a
little weird that someone in the middle
of a [ __ ] discussion has to go out
and go play just some van Halen and then
come back before they can be but you
know I you know I have some growing up
to do but whatever so that yeah that's
what I would do and you know I if you're
doing all of this already like this is
not gonna be the last opportunity how
much better would it be if you built
your own firm you know I think that
would be pretty badass all right but do
whatever you want to do but that that's
my that's my feeling sorry withdrawals
I've been listening to the podcast since
the first episode this is my third day
off of opiates congratulations
congratulations I've been on pain manage
pain management schedule for the last
five years due to arthritis in my spine
eating painkiller after painkiller for
the last five years eventually I got to
the point where I was starting to
question if I was addicted
or not every time I took a painkiller he
kind of skipped a few words there but
you're going through withdrawals the
fact that you have to be able to sit
down and [ __ ] write an email is a
victory in itself asking myself if I
still have it under control I'm a single
dad with the career I worked long hours
at night and I'm lucky enough to still
be there to get my son from school every
day I've never missed one of his games
or races but at the same time I've been
taking these painkillers every day it
felt like carrying a demon on my back
I'm only three days into being clean
still withdrawing still can't sleep skin
is crawling all of the normal symptoms
that hasn't stopped me from my daily
responsibilities though dude you're a
[ __ ] trooper nobody really knows that
I'm growing through this I don't open up
about things like this to people well
that's what you need to do immediately
he said which is why I'm writing you I
don't want anything in return just
wanted to vent to this to someone
I've been real istening to the podcast
to pass the time until these withdrawals
are over there's absolutely no chance
that I'll ever go back to painkillers I
feel miserable right now but it's the
best feeling I've had it felt in a long
time good for you no more demon on my
back well that's great well you need to
reach out to people because it's okay to
say that you need help and you know from
what I've heard you know getting off
opiates is is as difficult as trying to
kick heroin which is also an opiate
right I'm glad I don't know a lot about
drugs like that so you know I just yeah
definitely let people know what you're
going through
yeah I'll leave it at that that's that's
a heavy [ __ ] subject so it's a tough
[ __ ] guy man
jaysus skin crawling he's still doing
everything he needs to do for his family
he's um I'm not going back that's an
old-school [ __ ] guy John Wayne [ __ ]
right there anyways oh do be do be do
I'm gonna be on Jimmy Kimmel tonight
promoting the front row
movie starring Hugh Jackman it's the the
Gary hat story
directed by Jason Reitman I'm so psyched
to be in this movie truly is you know
one of the great things I've been able
to be a part of as far as being in an
ensemble so check that out tonight
and other than that I got to go buy a
shirt to wear on Kimmel cuz you know God
knows you can't wear the same shirt on
TV more than once can't do that you know
well you [ __ ] [ __ ] to make fun of
me who have you know ten shirts that are
in there you know that's you your
pitching staff that's your rotation ten
[ __ ] shirts yet show biz you're not
allowed to do that
you got to wear it once so what you do
is I always try to pick something that
you know it doesn't really stand out
just sort of a bland [ __ ] color you
get any sort of designs on it the people
like yeah it is now wearing it again was
I supposed to throw it out you're
wasteful [ __ ] anyway so I have to do
that
and I'm also gonna be you know I always
make pumpkin bread during between what
is it Halloween and Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving I start busting out the
pies I make my [ __ ] stuffing I'm
throwing down this year because I'm
gonna be in town I can't wait very
excited and I think my daughter's still
one year away from maybe going
trick-or-treating I don't know I left
half I'll have to ask my wife about that
but that's it go Patriots
congratulations to Lewis Hamilton Marc
Marquez the Boston Red Sox and yeah
that's it what a great [ __ ] week for
me as a sports fan all right and I'm not
rubbing it in either all right I hope
the Dodgers win it again next year if we
don't how's that that's the nicest thing
I could say all right okay that's it go
[ __ ] yourselves enjoy the next couple of
days please watch Paul virzi special
November 3rd on Comedy Central one of my
best friends in the world and I'm so
proud of him he's got a great great
great special that he did with the all
things comedy Network I'll check in on
Thursday